TEAM.
WE SHOT A COUPLE OF COMMERCIALS
TOGETHER.
NOTHING BUT LOVE AND RESPECT FOR
L.B.
>> EXACTLY.
AND ALSO SPEAKING OF LEGENDARY
CELTICS.
BILL RUSSELL.
THERE IS A HUGE AUCTION GOING ON
FRIDAY IN BOSTON.
BILL RUSSELL IS AUCTIONING OFF
HUNDREDS OF ITEMS.
TROPHIES, RINGS, YOU ARE TALKING
CARDS, WARM-UPS, JERSEYS.
IT IS GOING TO BENEFIT MENTOR, A
GROUP THAT HE IS VERY CLOSE WITH
AND THE BOSTON CELTICS UNITED
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THAT IS ALL HAPPENING ON
DECEMBER TENTH.
WHEN WE HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK
WITH BILL RUSSELL EARLIER
TONIGHT, AND YOU KNOW HE HAS GOT
A MILLION STORIES.
HE TOOK US WAY, WAY BACK FOR
THIS ONE.
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS IN
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND MY MOTHER
DIED.
SO, MY FATHER, MY BROTHER AND I.
MY FATHER GAVE ME A CHOICE OF
WHERE I WANTED TO GO TO HIGH
SCHOOL.
NOW MY BROTHER WAS OUT AT
OAKLAND TECH AND HE SAID TO ME
AT DINNER ONE NIGHT DO NOT TELL
ANYBODY YOU ARE MY BROTHER
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T PLAY AND IT
WILL RUIN MY REPUTATION.
>> THAT IS A CLASSIC.
11 RINGS LATER.
>> I GUESS HIS BROTHER WAS
WRONG.
>> I TELL YOU WHAT THOUGH.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME OF
THAT COLLECTION.
HE HAS BEEN GREAT TO ME ALL OF
THESE YEARS.
WHAT HE HAS DONE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY IS
UNMATCHED.
HIM AND ALI ALWAYS WILL BE MY
HEROES AS FAR AS THAT GOES.
EASY TO BE A SOCIAL JUSTICE GUY
MAKING $100 MILLION.
BUT ALL OF THE GUYS THAT DID THE
HEAVY LIFTING BACK IN THE DAY.
I THINK I MIGHT LOOK AT THE
AUCTION AND BID ON SOMETHING.
>> TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ALL 11 OF
HIS RINGS.
NOBODY IS OUTBIDDING ME ON THAT
ONE.
>> YOU THE RICHEST PERSON UP
HERE.
>> ACTUALLY ERNIE IS.
>> LISTEN.
>> I KNOW MICHAEL JORDAN AND
TIGER WOODS.
THEY HAVE MORE MONEY THAN SHAQ.
>> T